[Musique]
Clem est une société spécialisée dans
l'autopartage et la recharge de
véhicules électriques en 2022 nous avons
remporté le contrat de concession du
plateau de Saclay un groupement de
commandes avec les universités l'ACPS
l'établissement public pour promouvoir
la mobilité électrique à l'échelle du
plateau alors comment ça marche pour les
utilisateurs il faut s'inscrire sur le
site clem.mobi une fois inscrit on va
pouvoir réserver un véhicule en
autopartage après avoir mis son permis
de conduire et avoir été validé pour la
recharge il suffit de s'inscrire aussi
sur clem.mobi ou d'avoir un badge déjà
d'un autre opérateur et de venir juste
se recharger sur les bornes de charges
le système de facturation est lié à la
consommation horaire et kilowatts
aujourd'hui Clem est le seul acteur du
marché a proposé à la fois de
l'autopartage électrique et à la fois
des services de bande de charge
l'intérêt est de promouvoir une mobilité
décarbonée et partagée à l'échelle d'un
territoire à travers une seule
application les usagers peuvent trouver
tous les services à leur disposition
voire s'inscrire réserver payer et voir
leur bilan carbone à l'échelle du
plateau sur les 5 années à venir notre
objectif est premièrement de proposer
des usages forfait Flex des forfaits
garantis sur des véhicules de notre
flotte en autopartage mais aussi de
proposer à l'ensemble des acteurs du
territoire de venir se recharger sur les
bornes du territoire et dans un deuxième
temps notre objectif est de rencontrer
chacun des acteurs les acteurs de
l'immobilier les collectivités et les
entreprises qui travaillent sur le
plateau pour voir avec elle en fonction
de leurs besoins et de leurs contraintes
comment les aider à rentrer dans une
mobilité partagée et une mobilité
électrique c'est à dire des carbonées
donc nous avons trois offres
premièrement une offre de positionner
des bornes de charges pour leur compte
de positionner des voitures pour leur
flotte et de partager les bornes de
charges et les véhicules soit en interne
soit avec le tout public selon des
règles définies par eux le campus de
Paris-Saclay est une référence au niveau
mondial avec des acteurs variés et des
besoins variés de mobilité
ce campus est voué à se densifier
énormément dans les années à venir et
Clem est là pour accompagner ce
développement tout en proposant une
mobilité décarbonée et partagée
pour démarrer la voiture je mets le pied
sur frein j'appuie sur Start Stop
je mets ma ceinture
toujours le pied sur le frein je vais me
mettre en position drive je retire le
frein à main
et je vous dis à plus tard
[Musique]